- Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our Homeroom livestream,
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
For those of you who are
wondering what this is,
this is just something we
started up several months ago,
especially when we all have
to become socially distanced
as a way of having interesting topics
with interesting guests and
also taking your questions.
And I'm really excited
about our guest today,
Jacquelline Fuller from Google.org.
But before that,
I would like to give a special shout out
to several organizations that stepped up
when they realized that Khan Academy
was already running at
a deficit pre-COVID.
And our cost only went up
whether it's server costs
or we're trying to accelerate programs
or adding new content in
response to school closure.
So special, thanks to Google.org,
Bank of America, AT&T,
Fastly and Novartis.
I will say to all of
you listening out there
as much as help this has
been from the support of
these great organizations.
We are still running at
a deficit and as we know
the school closure
issue, isn't going away.
So we're trying to do what we can,
but if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to Khanacademy.org/donate.
We only exist because of
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So any level of donation makes a big deal.
So please think about doing that.
So with that, I'm excited
about introducing our guest
Jacquelline Fuller
president of Google.org,
Jacquelline great to have you here.
- Great to be here to chat with you Sal.
- And maybe a good place to start.
Obviously everyone knows Google,
some folks know Google.org.
What is Google.org?
Why does it exist?
What does the.org mean?
- So Google.org is Google's philanthropy
and essentially we're
a part of the company.
We're a team embedded fully within Google.
And the idea is to think about
how can we use the unique
strengths of Google
to make the world better?
And specifically,
how can we address issues
like education, inclusion?
More recently taking on
issues like the COVID crisis,
by doing so in a way that brings together
the best of Google, all of our assets.
So we're funded through a 1%
commitment of our companies
and our profits each year.
So it's funding North of $200 million,
but we also think about
Google's strengths in technology
and our Googlers are
amazingly passionate employees
who also wanna step in.
And so we often combine teams of Googlers
who go and work alongside nonprofits,
along with funding,
along with our reach and
our voice and advocacy.
- And just to be clear,
I mean, this is a little
bit of a disclosure,
but also I wanna give
you and Google credit
for all of those who enjoy Khan Academy.
A lot of people don't realize
Khan Academy back in 2010 ...
Actually was 2009.
When we started ...
This conversation started
when it was just me
actually in the same walk-in-closet
that I'm in right now.
The folks at Google
y'all were down the road,
about three miles down
the road talking about
ways to educate the world.
There was this ten to
the hundredth project
and Khan Academy was one of those projects
and y'all gave a significant
donation at the time ...
I mean, it's significant today too.
It was a $2 million donation
that essentially allowed
Khan Academy to exist.
And so I don't wanna
embarrass you too much
with too much praise, but we
would not exist from that.
And then since then
Google.org has been sponsor
or a supporter of multiple
projects at Khan Academy.
But Jacquelline, maybe just ...
I encourage everyone watching
to ask any questions you have
for Jacquelline or myself
on YouTube or on Facebook,
and I'll surface them,
but Jacquelline maybe to
make it more tangible,
give examples of the types of stuff
I gave one my favorite example
(laughing)
y'all have supported,
but what other types of things do y'all do
either in kind of the
traditional philanthropic support
or in that Google has special
skills type of support?
- Well, one that's very topical
right now that comes to mind
is we're investing in racial
justice organizations.
And particularly we've
had a historic commitment
to helping to fight mass incarceration
and to look at racial justice reform.
So about five years ago,
Justin Steele on my team led
an initiative where we asked,
"What can Google do uniquely
to help with this issue
"of deep systemic bias?"
And so we invested resources
North of $32 million
in fabulous partners
like Bryan Stevenson org,
Equal Justice Initiative,
organizations such as a
Center for Policing Equity
run by dr. Phil Goff.
And so we invested in organizations
who were bringing
together data and science
and trying to figure out how can we solve
some of these issues
that are deeply rooted
in systemic bias,
but were having more data and evidence
and where technology can
really come to the forefront.
So we had a historic commitment
there and more recently
because of the movement that's
been happening across the U.S
we really wanted to make sure
that these frontline orgs
orgs that are led by people of color
and really looking at
what are the solutions
that are enhanced.
So we reinvested in them
and sent resources and
additional $12 million,
but also Googlers.
I mean, we have passionate Googlers
who have unique skillsets that
they can bring to the table.
So for example, working
with the Vera Institute,
a team of Google engineers
and product managers
and UX folks,
and even marketing folks came
alongside the Vera Institute
and helped bring together
for the first time ever
data around jails around the countries.
We talk a lot about federal prisons,
but most folks are in jails
and there's not really one
authoritative data source
that helps us look at
who's being incarcerated?
What are the demographic characteristics?
How many are in, for example,
just because they can't
pay bonds, jail bonds?
So that's the kind of work that we do,
where we empower these
frontline organizations
to do what they're doing
and help build them
through not only the
funding and the resources,
but through Googlers.
- I'm just curious.
It sounds like y'all have been
doing this for a little while
and y'all are accelerating some of this
around social justice, racial justice,
any kind of surprising insights
out of that about the data.
How many people are there for ...
I'm just making up stuff,
nonviolent offenses
or for not being able to pay
bond or things like that.
- Yeah. I mean, it's fascinating.
And viewers can go to the
Center for Policing Equity
or the Vera Institute.
Vera just published the
data that we helped them
put together with this product.
But for example, you see
that the numbers incarcerated
were pretty steady through about 1980,
and then it just hits an escal
that looks a lot like COVID
just starts to accelerate and you see
just how the percentage
that are incarcerated
and percentages by race.
So for example, looking at how right now,
because of COVID, for
example politicians leaders
are having to think about
is this a time where we actually release
some offenders folks who are
in prisons and jails early
in part because of COVID
and having the data to do so
in an informed way to say,
"Hey, these are nonviolent offenders.
"These are folks who are a
very low risk to society."
So that is an example of two streams
of very current research and
needs for data coming together.
COVID and mass incarceration.
- Yeah. And related to that,
I have a question here from YouTube,
Susanna Garcia Dominguez.
Who's one of our regular
great question askers.
Says,
"Hi, Jacquelline, what are some of your
"innovative projects
dealing with COVID-19?"
- Well, it's interesting with COVID.
So my background is I used to
work at the Gates Foundation.
So I come from the field of
global health originally.
And it's just amazing how
little we actually know,
how much data we actually
have on who's being infected,
how they're being infected.
And this is particularly
true in the case of COVID
for underrepresented groups.
We know that COVID is
impacting, for example,
the black community and
the Latino community
at much higher rates than
say the white community.
We know that they are
black and brown people
are more likely to be infected.
They're more likely to be
hospitalized and unfortunately,
more likely to die as well.
But the data there to
understand exactly where
the hotspots and what
interventions are working
is not there.
So we just teamed up with the
Morehouse School of Medicine
who has been doing some excellent
work to gather more data,
to help inform particularly
how COVID is impacting
members of minority communities.
So we gave them a million dollar grant,
but we also send, again a team of Googlers
to work with them on the data.
And one thing that
happened with that project,
now, that was a fairly recent project.
And about the last month or so,
and particularly at the from
the Google expertise side,
helping with the use of AI,
Artificial Intelligence
and Machine learning,
to make sure that we're taking that data
and helping the teams there,
turn that into actionable information.
But the Department of
Health and Human Services
came alongside us in that
project very quickly afterwards
and invested an additional 40 million.
And I think that that's a good
example of what philanthropy
can do because at the end of the day,
the real engines of change,
the real engines of scale
are the market and government.
But I think philanthropy can play a role
where we're more catalytic
where we can help really at the beginning.
Kind of like we did with UCL
to help give that seed funding
at the beginning to say,
this is a brilliant idea.
We love Khan Academy.
We believe in it.
Let's help invest in it in the beginning.
Let's help send technology teams as well.
So we're trying to do
that with COVID as well.
- Yeah, no, it's super,
and there's a bunch of
questions coming in.
But actually it would be interesting ...
I think one of the fun things
about this live stream is
we have a lot of young people watching.
They're trying to figure
out their own lives.
I remember being young,
I guess I'm not anymore.
And looking at people that
seem successful and say,
"How did they get there?"
So maybe it'd be fun to
take a little step back,
but then I do wanna ask
where you hope Google
and Google.org goes, but
just your own personal,
how did you get into this career?
Is this a career like running a foundation
or a corporate foundation or philanthropy?
I mean, it is a career, but like
there's no major in college around it.
So tell us a little bit about
what you thought you
were gonna do growing up
and how that evolved to where you are now.
- Yes, I did not grow up as a
little girl thinking to myself
someday I wanna run
corporate philanthropy.
So this was a bit of a zigzag
trail to get to where I am.
And so I actually
started when I was young,
having a very strong
commitment to social justice
and not really understanding or knowing
how I could best make an impact.
But just having that as
kind of my Northern Star,
like I knew I really wanted
to invest myself and my time
and my effort, my skills into an area
where I was moving the
needle on social justice.
So I actually started
right out of college.
I went to work in the
government because at the time,
if you wanted to change things at scale,
you joined the government.
So I worked actually at
the Department of Health
and Human Services
in Washington, DC and I was,
I think the most junior
person you could possibly hire
at the time, but I worked on
issues of health disparities
actually, with minority
communities and under
Dr. Louis Sullivan, who was
the Head of HHS at the time
and was actually
coincidentally the founder of
the Morehouse School of Medicine.
So, coming full circle.
So I worked in government
for a couple of years,
and then I thought I really
would like to invest in myself,
deepen my understanding, my knowledge,
my technical skills as well.
So I went and got a
master's in public policy
from the Kennedy School of Government.
And while I was there
actually got pregnant.
And my husband and I had a nice surprise
when I was in graduate school.
So we had our first daughter, Hosanna.
So I took some time where I
really focused on being a mom
to two young kids.
And then when I went back
to work after a few years,
there's this new startup,
we were living in Seattle at the time,
called the Gates Foundation.
I read an article where Bill Gates said,
"I'm gonna give the
majority of my money away
"and I'm gonna give it to
help the poorest of the poor."
And I just thought,
"Hire me. I will help you."
(laughing)
So I threw myself at the
gates of the Gates Foundation
and eventually got a job there.
I was there for about eight years,
and then I heard about
another crazy startup
called Google.org.
And I thought,
"Okay, I've worked in government
"and private philanthropy.
"I've never actually worked in a company.
"I'd like to see what companies can do.
"And this sounds like a
very interesting startup."
So I came down to join
Google.org about 12 years ago.
- Yeah.
And your path is very connected
to us because back in 2010,
the two organizations that
frankly allowed Khan Academy
to become a real organization were
Google and the Gates Foundation
with that first round.
And then have obviously since
then been great supporters,
it's all connected.
- It's all connected.
- What do you think has
kind of contributed to
your success here?
What do you think has made
you good at what you do?
- It's not really boring when I say this,
but number one is hard work.
I think I had to outwork a lot of people
to get to where I am and
be smarter and be better
and be more resilient and have grit.
And I think that's kind of been
a new boutique area of study.
Angela, I think Duckworth and others
have really looked into-
- Former guest.
- Oh, she's fabulous.
And have really done the
research studies on grit
and how important of a
characteristic that is.
But I mentioned, for example,
when I was at the Kennedy School
I had my daughter Hosanna,
in the middle of my second
year and Kennedy School said,
"We recommend you leave."
And I said,
"No, I think I'm gonna graduate."
And they gave me no parental leave.
There was no such thing at the time.
It didn't actually exist.
And so I had her on a
Thursday and I went back to
school on Monday and I got-
- Wow.
- I had gotten no break.
I had to finish every single thesis
and experience and whatnot.
So there have been times
in my career where I think
really digging deep, having
that grit and perseverance
and hard work is super important.
I would say the other thing Sal,
is I just have always
run towards my energy.
I've always run towards
what really lights me up.
We hear a lot about follow your
passion, but at some level,
I think it's actually true.
Find that source of energy
that really is gonna
get you up in the morning
and help you read that research article.
So run towards your energy,
but also ask yourself,
"And how am I gonna get paid to do this?"
And where can I uniquely plug in?
Where can I make the most
difference, follow my energy,
but realistically be
able to build a career
and some wellbeing that's
gonna be sustainable.
So I never really had a path like,
"Oh, I definitely wanna
work in philanthropy,
"or I definitely wanna do this or that."
But I've used more of those
guidelines and characteristics.
- And definitely is.
I mean, there's just even
the story you told us,
the fact that you read about
the Gates Foundation starting,
I think a lot of the world
probably read about it,
but there's something and you said,
"I want them to hire me."
But I think-
- And they said, no.
- It's a mindset.
And they said, no? Okay.
They said, no.
And then what happened?
- They said no so many times.
So the article came out,
and the Gates Foundation
was just starting and it was
very much in stealth mode.
And so they said that reporter
was led into their office,
which was in a above a pizza
shop in Redmond, Washington.
And so I drove over to
Redmond, Washington,
and I looked at all the pizza shops
and I look for one with
an office above it.
And I basically figured
out where they were.
And then I would go there every day
and I would shove my
resume and my cover letter
into their mailbox and make a case for
why they needed to hire
me and why I would be
so great on their team.
And then they would email me
back a very polite rejection.
And that happened like three times.
And this is a true story, Sal.
This is a true story.
And then after the third time,
literally I got this
email from Jack Barris,
who said I will meet you for 15 minutes
at Starbucks in Redmond,
if you promise to never bother us again.
- Wow.
- And he ended up hiring me.
You stalked the Gates Foundation.
- I was persistent.
I showed some grit.
- You were persistent.
- I made the case of why
I brought them value.
I've learned that you don't make the case,
young people, people who
are trying to get a job,
do not make the case of why
such and such is your dream job.
Don't convince Sal, that
working at the Khan Academy
is your dream job convince Sal,
that you are gonna be a value to him,
that you are going to
make his life easier,
that you are bringing a skillset
that he desperately needs.
'Cause that's one thing
I've learned as an employer
and sitting on the
other side of the table.
- And that's right.
As much as you know, I would
like to believe that yes,
you are directly drawn to people
who can make your life easier
and who can help fulfill a
broader mission or vision
that you are part of or invested in.
Well, I am curious.
I mean, this is a much
more interesting story
than I expected when we kind of started
double clicking on it.
What was that meeting like?
I mean, this person who's kind
of trying to get rid of you.
You've been sending them a resumes,
not taking no for an answer.
I'm assuming he didn't
have the posture of like,
"I'm really excited
about this conversation."
- No, but he was a gracious man.
That's why I name him.
And look, I also had to be
flexible on my end, right?
I had a degree.
I had published research.
I was funded by the Ford Foundation
to do some of my own research.
And when I was pitching myself,
I was pitching myself more as,
"Hey, I can help with econometrics.
"I can do measurement and evaluation."
There are all these various public policy.
And he was like,
"Yeah, I don't think we're
ready actually for advocacy
"or public policy and I
don't actually even know
what econometrics are but thank you."
But he started to think, and he was like,
"You're a very good writer.
"And we actually need someone
to write our brochure."
And so I was literally hired,
in order to write their brochure.
So a couple of lessons here,
especially for women and girls
who might be listening.
One thing is
I think sometimes we have
to get our foot in the door
and being willing to be
a little bit flexible.
And the other thing is when he said,
we need someone to write our
first brochure and to design it
and work with vendors
and get it published.
And he said,
"Is that something you can do?"
And I started to do the
typical girl thing, like,
"Well, I've never done that before,
but I'd be happy to try."
Some spirit came up out
of me and I was like,
"Absolutely, I can do that."
And so I was hired
on contract to do their first
brochure and it went okay.
And then they were like,
"We actually need someone now
"to create our first website.
"Is that something you can do?"
And again, so I had zero
experience with websites.
I barely understood the internet
and could function on email at the time.
But I said,
"Absolutely, I can
absolutely build a website."
And so I think sometimes just
being brave, taking that step
believing in yourself and
then eventually I got hired.
And when I left,
I was the Deputy Director
of the Global Health Program
eight years later.
And I used to bring Bill and Melinda Gates
to Africa and India and
Pakistan and all over the world
for weeks at a time to do
their learning and their
education, advocacy trips.
So really appreciate
that Gates was willing to
take a bet on me early in my career.
- No, and there's a lot of ...
Because we learn a little lesson is
you had some real skills
that you had built over time.
And so the real message
for those young people,
I feel old now whenever I say that,
but for those young
young people listening is
build up your skills as well as possible.
And in that, I think the writing skill,
the critical thinking skill and just
the can-do witness skill,
then with a little sprinkle of resilience
and self confidence can go a
long way is what I'm hearing.
- Yeah.
And especially I get
asked a lot from people
who really wanna have a
career in social impact.
And I bet you get this a lot to Sal,
where people are saying they're
coming fresh out of college,
maybe a few years out and they're saying,
"I wanna make a difference.
"I really wanna invest
my whole self, my career
"in social justice or making an impact,
"changing the world,
changing climate change."
I often tell them the most
important thing you can do
right now is to build and
develop a tangible hard skill.
And that hard skill can be writing,
it can be critical writing.
It can be coding,
it can be finance and auditing.
It can be PR,
be an excellent product manager,
but really the nonprofit sector,
the government, philanthropy,
the do-gooder sector
needs people with hard
skills and experience.
So invest in yourself,
develop those skills
and do that first and bring
those into your lifetime career.
- And there's a question
here from YouTube,
from a Jasper Not Even a Rapper says,
"Jacquelline, what would you
say to help market yourself
"in a climate where your
degree might not apply
"or be useful skill?"
And this is a very relevant
question right now,
obviously we're at record
levels of unemployment.
There's new jobs, new
industries all the time
that have no degrees for them.
How does someone transition
or if their resume
doesn't say that they're meant for that.
How do they convince folks?
- Great question, Jasper.
You heard my story and the fact that
I had to believe in myself
and be willing to really learn
and do different things
and come into a job
where I was gonna have
a steep learning curve.
So I think part of it is
that flexibility on our part.
As people, I think also ...
Look, the world is changing
so much and degrees,
especially what major you were in,
what grades you got in your major.
I think these kinds of things are gonna
matter less and less,
and it's gonna be a lot
about lifelong learning.
So using resources like
Khan Academy, for example,
learning, taking new
skills, new certifications
are gonna make you very
relevant in the job market.
I will say the other thing Jasper,
is that we need to change.
The employers need to change.
We need to get off of
our fixation on degrees
and four year degrees really,
and actually hire for skills.
And that's gonna really help us to have
a more diverse workforce,
it's gonna really help
us build better products.
And so at Google, for example,
one thing that we have done
is to really try to
reevaluate our requirements
for our jobs and to really
state a four-year college degree
not required or CS major not required,
if you have the skills at
hand needed for this role.
So there's movement that's
needed on both sides of that.
- No, that's super valuable.
And I realized these conversations,
they always go away faster
than I expect them to because
I could talk for another hour,
just even on the career aspect of it.
But I wanna make sure that
there's space to talk about
kind of the future of
Google.org and your work there.
And maybe we can even connect to that.
There's this question from YouTube,
from Neupro Mitha,
"How hard is it to run a company?"
I mean, that goes into a
whole kind of your day to day
and what are your stresses or your hopes
and maybe how does that flow
into what you hope Google.org
is able to do over the years to come?
- Well, someone said to me once,
and I didn't believe it at the time.
I thought they were making it up,
but it it was a female executive.
I'm forgetting who, but she said,
it's actually easier to
be CEO than it was to be
like a line director.
It's actually easier sometimes
as you move up the food chain
because you're able to
control your schedule more,
control your life more,
focus on the things that you're good at
and hire excellent people
to cover all of the areas
that you're really not good at.
And so I would say that that's true
and I see that as a word of encouragement
to people who are maybe wondering
if they have what it takes
to go to that next level to be CEO or COO,
or to run the show at whatever level.
And I think sometimes when
you're looking up at that.
and you think,
"Well, I'm working so hard right now,
"and I'm so stressed right now.
"It must be 10X at that level."
Actually, sometimes it's easier
because you have more control.
So that's just something to
consider about the question
about being the boss
and I've always believed
also I was told early on
hire people who are smarter
and better than you are,
don't be threatened by them.
And so I have always
tried to hire an A-team.
My deputies are smarter
better than me in so many ways
and empowering your people
so that you're not alone.
There's not this loneliness at the top
or feeling that you're carrying the weight
of Atlas on your shoulders.
I've built a very
collaborative leadership team
where I feel like we are
carrying the load together.
I have people like Hannah
Peter, for example,
who's running our education portfolio
and has done a lot of the work
that we've been doing more recently
with Khan Academy with DonorsChoose
and being able to trust someone like her,
Andrew Dunkelman and say,
"Hey, you all have this,
"I'm gonna just listen to
your recommendations here."
Has been amazing in terms
of increasing the impact
that Google.org can have,
and frankly helping me
to be a better leader
- And what with that lens.
And I think I need some coaching from you
because I definitely have things
that I'm always coping with.
And the loneliness is part of
it sometimes if I'm honest.
- Yeah.
- But what is your hope for ...
Actually I'll broaden it
for Google.org over the years to come
and even for your own direct impact
either through Google.org or broadly?
- I mean, Sal my dream
is actually that we find
and fund and support and empower
a thousand Sal Khan, right?
You are actually our success story, right?
Because our job is to invest,
provide the seed funding,
the catalytic funding
that is necessary.
And I think philanthropic
capital can take risks.
And companies like Google tech companies
can be particularly useful I think
when it comes to investing in technology,
a lot of funders and governments
and private individuals
don't feel like they know
or understand enough about,
let's say technology or
artificial intelligence,
they're just not going to
invest those organizations.
So that's something I think
we should always ask ourselves
either as individuals, as companies,
"Where am I uniquely gifted?
"How can I make a difference
"that builds on my unique strengths?"
So for Google.org, we are Google.
We are a technology company
and technology is desperately needed
in the social impact sector.
So that's where we're doubling down.
So when an issue comes up
like education, or COVID,
we think about what are the platforms?
What are the scaled ways that
are leveraging technology
where we could have really
helped shift the curve?
So Sal, when you came along ...
I don't know if I've
ever told you this story,
but part of it was that my husband, John
is an elementary school teacher,
and he has been a classroom
teacher for almost 30 years.
And he was an early user
of the Khan Academy.
- Oh, I need to send
him a box of chocolates.
- Oh man. A big box and with
some dark chocolate in there
because his wife likes it.
- Absolutely.
- But I saw firsthand what
a difference Khan Academy
made for a classroom teacher
and then later in life.
So my daughter Hosanna who was born.
I said, when I was in grad school.
So she majored in computer
science actually in college.
And when she needed help
with help with her homework
or her problem sets,
or really wanted to understand something
that was happening in the classroom,
she went to Khan Academy and she was ...
So you were tremendously
helpful in her career.
So I've been personally
able to see firsthand
how helpful Khan Academy is.
That's why we invested in
the beginning, but then also,
I benefited from those fruits
later on with my daughter
where I think particularly as
a female in computer science,
it was tremendously helpful for her
to have a resource to go to.
- No, well, that's
always wonderful to hear.
And actually you never did tell,
I mean, back in 2000, and
it was actually 2009 when
we started first having the conversations
with Google I remember, I
was kind of overwhelmed,
not knowing what to make of it.
I used to walk around with
these little like placemats slides.
And I remember there was a big
room of folks that said like,
"What would you do with more resources?
"A lot of us have been using it.
"We didn't realize you were
just some guy in a closet
"operating three miles down the road."
(laughing)
It was all interesting time.
It's fun to talk about
it in hindsight now,
but yeah, it was interesting.
Well, Jacquelline,
I mean, we've gotta do this
again if you're up for it,
but we're unfortunately all out of time.
But any final thoughts,
words, words of wisdom, ideas,
things you wanna throw out there.
- I mean, we are in a moment
right now, not only in the US,
but globally, we are in a moment.
There's something like 2 billion kids
who are not able to go
to the traditional
schooling that they had.
If there was ever a moment,
for the Khan Academy to come
up and shine and be utilized.
It is this moment.
So I don't think I mentioned earlier,
but we actually just regranted
again to Khan Academy.
He did not ask me to say
this, but let me say,
we just gave additional funding
in the last couple months.
because we recognize
this is a global moment
where we need to be investing in platforms
that hit scale that are
available in local languages,
in content that teachers can use.
Teachers are the heroes,
they are the frontline essential workers.
This is a way that we
can all invest in them.
So thank you, Khan Academy.
Thank you, Sal.
Thank you, everyone out there
who is working to make
the world a better place
in your own unique way.
This is that moment.
- Yeah.
Well, obviously I couldn't agree more
and Jacquelline, thank you so
much for obviously the work
that you've been able to do with us
and help us, help do our mission,
but also well beyond that.
The incredible work that you all
are doing at google.org.com.
Thank you so much for joining.
- Thanks so much, Sal.
Appreciate it.
- Thank you.
So thanks everyone for joining as always.
My perception of time changes
when we're having a good conversation.
It goes by very, very fast,
but as you can tell another
really, really fun conversation.
We're not going to be doing
a live stream tomorrow,
but we will be having, I think Tuesday.
We're gonna be coming back.
We have two guests next week.
Both very, very interesting.
Casey Wasserman, famous
I guess you could say,
agent in the sports and
entertainment world.
So I think it should be
some really interesting
conversation there.
And you might not have heard
of this guy, Dr. Anthony Fauci,
to talk about obviously the situation
that we're all in together.
So we look forward to
seeing you next week.